king charles iii hasn't just become the
reigning monarch of the united kingdom
he's now officially the head of state
for 14 countries outside of the uk known
as commonwealth realms from australia
and canada to belize and the bahamas now
some of those countries are having fresh
debates about cutting ties with the
monarchy but even if there's popular
support legal experts and scholars say
that abolishing the british monarch as
head of state can be legally challenging
so here's a look at some of the
countries talking about becoming
republics and the challenges they could
face moving forward
the 14 countries that have kept the
british monarch as their sovereign were
all part of the british empire
and just like in the uk the role of the
monarch in these realms is largely
symbolic and ceremonial king charles
doesn't have much actual power while
some people like the idea of having a
unifying figure who transcends politics
others believe for various reasons that
it's time to cut ties in countries like
australia and new zealand my colleague
mike cerny says a lot of people simply
want a head of state that's from
australia or new zealand they they
really chafe at this idea that the head
of state of their country
is basically a person who lives on the
other side of the planet the prime
ministers of both countries have
expressed support for replacing the
monarch but not necessarily right now i
believe it's likely to occur in my
lifetime it's a different story in some
caribbean realms like jamaica antigua
and barbuda and saint vincent and the
grenadines where there is more urgency
to cut ties fundamentally it goes to the
question of slavery which is a very
living memory in the caribbean as one
historian has said
the caribbean was britain's south
the caribbean was where all of this
happened on recent trips to the region
prince william and his wife kate were
met with protests and calls for
apologies and reparations in a speech
prince william expressed his sorrow for
britain's role in slavery slavery was
abhorrent
and it should never have happened during
that trip the prime minister of jamaica
told him that the country intends to
break free of the royal family we are
moving on
and shortly after the queen's death the
prime minister of antigua and barbuda
told itv news that he plans to hold a
referendum to cut ties in the coming
years it is the final step as i said
before to complete that circle of
independence but legally experts say
that the process of cutting ties and
changing constitutions isn't necessarily
easy huge challenges possibly
insuperable derek o'brien a researcher
of caribbean constitutional law told me
that in the remaining realms the legal
bar is quite high unlike barbados which
only required a special majority vote in
parliament to become a republic last
year most remaining caribbean realms
require by law both a special majority
vote among lawmakers and a successful
referendum and in some realms the
referendum must get two-thirds of the
vote to pass as much as i would wish to
do it i can't without your consent
i'll have to have a referendum and the
behavior people have to say to me yes
derek says those are huge hurdles and he
points out that several referendums have
failed in the past like in saint vincent
antigua and the bahamas i mean there are
a number of factors but one common
denominator was they lacked bipartisan
support over in australia a republic
referendum failed in 1999. some believe
it's because voters didn't like the
alternative plan of picking a new head
of state and in new zealand a treaty
viewed as a founding document of the
country is between the indigenous maori
and the british crown each country has
its own sort of legal situation that
needs to be untangled in canada where a
poll showed that half of canadians don't
think the country should continue as a
constitutional monarchy the legal bar
might be the highest there would have to
be unanimous consent among the country's
federal parliament and all 10 provincial
legislatures
while there appears to be a surge of
support for the royal family in the wake
of queen elizabeth's death experts say
that this global debate over who the
british monarch should represent is
likely to intensify in the coming months
[Music]